ha sido un buen sábado para francia que
ha cosechado varias medallas la última
de éstas fue en plata en la final de
rugby 7 las clases as perdieron ante las
neozelandesas más temprano en windsurf
charlín aquí con la medallista de oro en
la río se llevó la plata así como toma a
goya también hubo medalla de bronce de
los franceses en el triatlón de relevos
son mixtos eeuu se llevó la plata
mientras que gran bretaña se llevó el
oro en tenis sorpresa a novak djokovic
perdió ante pablo carreño busta fue el
español quien se quedó con la medalla de
bronce pero un bronce además que sí
gusto fue para brasil ya que laura
pigossi luisa stephanie ganaron su
partido en dobles femeninos al equipo
ruso y por último pues este sábado que
comenzó con récord mundial en la piscina
del centro acuático de tokio gracias a
que la frase del nadador estadounidense
que se impuso en los 100 metros mariposa
además con un récord mundial de 49
segundos y 95 centésimas